amit megemlítettél az hogy hogy isten
gyermekei
vagyunk hogy isten hasonlatosságára
vagyunk teremtve ez egy identitás de ez
egy kollektív identitás ez rád is
érvényes és rám is érvényes mit mondanál
az egyéni identitásról honnan lehet
megtudni hogy nekem milyen az
identitásom mit jelent az milyen vagyok
valójában és mi az ami engem szabolcsá
tesz és nem
editti pontosan valahogy úgy ragadnám
meg ezt a gondolatot hogy a megvált is
ha azt vesszük tucat de akkor lesz az
enyém ha én mondok igent rá és ott indul
el valami mélyenben mélyenben történő
hogy engem editté tud tenni mert ott
kibontakozik a terv tehát nem mindegy
hogy valamiről mondókázok vagy valamit
csak mantrázok vagy az enyém lesz tehát
az egyéni döntések alapján valahol
mélyen megragadható az hogy ki vagyok én
editként ki vagyok én bolcsként és az
egyéni döntésekben vagy az egyéni
választásokba beleszületik vagy
megszületik már az eredetileg adott
válasz ami kibomlik az uton és egy picit
itt az utonlét kapcsán is beemelnék
egy-két gondolatot engem nagyon sokszor
megérintett hogy
egyéni identitás témakörben maradván
akár hogy mindenkor az újszövetségben
amikor jézus tesz valamit nem épp
mindenkor de elég gyakran helyesbitek
úton történik tehát útközben történik
valami ugye hogyha mi szemleljük a saját
életeinket szabolcs te a tiedet én az
enyémet tehát útközben vagyunk valami
felé tartunk valamit
képviselünk amikor jézus az útközben
létben tesz valamit tehát a történések
mélysége
úgy jelenik meg hogy például hozok
konkrét példát tehát a vérfolyásos
asszony története ott van a kílódása és
a harca több évre visszavezettető harca
és amikor meglátja vagy meghallja hogy
jézus közeledik az úon a tömegen
átverekedve magát oda közeledik hozzá és
megérinti a ruháját és erőárad belőle és
ott jön a gyógyulás vagy ugye ott van az
út közben létben akár amikor a
vagbtimeus vagy nagyon sok az emausi
tanítványoknak a példája tehát nagyon
sok példa támasztja alá hogy
úton vagyunk a fejlődés az igazi értelem
az igazi hogy maradjunk ennél a szónál
akkor hogy cél
megtalálásnál a célokat szeretem
felruházni értékekkel és igazából ugye
az a cél ami ugye a szívet tudja
dobogtatni mert hogy a célon felül az
igazi értelem megtalálás és itt amit
akár az útközben való történés is megejt
ugye alátámasztja azt hogy szabad nekem
úton lennem és szabad nekem akár most
még annál a válasznál tartanom hogy nem
biztos hogy tudom hogy még most az
identitásomban ki vagyok valaha tudjuk
amúgy ezt amikor lesznek van van végső
megnyugvás az identitásunkban igen ugye
érdekes egy picit visszamennék akkor a
vérfolyásos asszony történetéhez ő addig
vérfolyásos volt de utána és a
vérfolyásosság meghatározta az ő
identitását tehát ő számkivetett volt
azzal hogy vérfolyásos asszony
megpecsételt volt tehát társadalmi
stigmák helyeződtek rá elkülönített
helyen való tartózkodás akár ugye a
leprások történetét is ismervén egy
picit tovább lépek miután lett a
gyógyulása ő már gyógyulttá váló lett
gyógyulttá vált és az identitásábaan ott
már a gyógyult vagyok ékelődött be és
érts jól tehát mindannyian valahonnan
elkezdünk lépdelni a gyógyulás van aki a
gyógyulás van aki a felépülés van aki az
értelem igenlés megtalálás irányába és
ott nincs cak hogy ne változzon az
identitás most érts jól tehát az
identitásunkra való lálátás tehát ugye a
vérfolyásos asszony vérfolyásosból
gyógyult lett tehát valahol ez a célja
így a segítői területemnek is vagy a
segítői szakterületem beölelésének
úgymond hogy valahol az az identitás
képződjön hogy voltam valaki akkor ott
az volt az életem részét képezi bele
lefordíthatom úgy a jelenembe hogy nem
egy veszteség fókusszal hanem egy
győzelmi fókusszal most vagyok valaki
mert elmozdultam onnan abba az irányba
és mindig az aki vagyok meghatároz
mélyen engem kérdezted hogy van-e olyan
hogy véglegesen
befejeződött érdekes ez a kérdés nincs
olyan tehát folyamatos keresésben
vagyunk és ha nem lenne ez a keresés és
a keresésen belül a megérke
utána ismét a keresés ez is kiüresítené
a létet na de bár itt azért fontos
tisztázzunk akkor valamit hogy
igen az hogy nincs megnyugvás és
folyamatosan változik az identitásunk ez
ijesztően hangzik ez az egyik és a másik
hogy posztmodernnek hangzik és tudom
hogy te nem így gondolod kíváncsi vagyok
hogy így gondolod-e
hogy olyan mintogyha egy homályos
szemüvegen keresztül látnánk a világot
és valamit lát vélünk a világból valami
célt amiele hívva vagyunk és ahogy
elkezdünk az úton haladni
egy-egy stációban egyre tisztábbá válik
hogy az az elhívásunk az micsoda és
rájöttünk hogy nem pontosan az volt mint
amire gondoltunk de útközben módosul az
az identitás de nem válik ellenkezőjévé
nem az van hogy egyik pillanatról a
másikra pont az ellenkezőjét fogom
gondolni a világról hanem egyre
pontosabban fogom látni inkább a célt és
ezáltal vagyunk folyamatosan úton de nem
kaotikus ez az egész út hanem egy egyre
inkább tisztázódó és egyre kevésbé
mocskos szemüvegen keresztül fogjuk
látni a
világot pontosan köszi szépen még
számomra is egy picit ijesztő volt ahogy
mondtad hogy és akkor nincs megnyugvás
de van megnyugvás csak egy tisztítottabb
látás kapcsán vagy tisztítottabb látás
keretén belül tudjunk már szemlélni és
ugye ide megint egy picit behozom azt
hogy vagyok halló vagy meghalló vagyok
látó vagy meglátóak a uflandos példádnál
maradván tehát van olyan hogy van
megnyugvás sőt beleékelődik úgy a
személyisségünk abba az elfogadottságba
hogy én ez vagyok az vagyok akit szeret
az isten az vagyok aki a teremtettség
részét úgy képezem a gyúgytöltömbe hogy
megvan a terv ha most még nem is vagyok
annyira teljesen kibontakozva vagy
kibontakozóban arra a tervre nézve de
úton vagyok és a történések útközben
jönnek létre
eszembe jutott még egy gondolat így a
tervekkel meg az útközbenléttel
kapcsolatosan tehát a lassú lépéseknek
az elve nagyon szeretem ezt támogatni
tehát mindenkor pici parcellákban
haladni abba az irányba amit
megszeretnénk ragadni tehát ez is egy
identitásképző állapot merek pici
lépésekbe haladni nem nagy bummokkal
változzunk hogy rögtön és akkor
türelmetlenül várjuk hogy jó már a
tegnap napra kész lett volna szükséges
hogy legyen és olyan érdekes ide
beemelek egy gondolatot egy kérdést
igazából emlékszem a pasztorál
pszichológia tanulmányaim keretén belül
tevődött föl ez a kérdés számomra egy
nagyon-nagyon drága tanárom ajkairól
úgy
kérdezett rá az élet
értelmére hogy ha az életünk végig végig
tartana itt a földön tehát nem lenne egy
véges ége szerintetek lenne-e értelme és
úgy hagyott egy pici gondolkodni való
időt tehát a halallhatatlanság pontosan
ha itt lenne a földön de hogy végig itt
lennénk a földön és nem lenne vége 8090
akárhány éves
korban emlékszem hogy olyan mélyen
érintett a kérdés első voltam aki a
kezeimet nagyon gyorsan emeltem a még
hamar előhívta a válaszomat és azt
mondtam hogy nem lenne akkora értelme
mert úgy túl eltolnunk mindent de így az
hogy vannak életszakaszok tehát vannak
olyan részek ahol most elidőzhetek mert
ifjúkoromban más az életfeladatom mint
már amikor három gyerekes anyuka vagyok
én ugye történetesen hogy az idősornak
ismét más az élet feladata tehát van
amikor gyökérverés ami minket érint vagy
gyökérverő állapotokat élünk meg de de
van amikor már szányképző állapotokba
megyünk bele van amikor már a termést
ami a szányképzésből bejött azt már
begyűjtjük azt már tovább akarjuk adni
ott már szólítani akarunk föl embereket
nemes feladatokra hogy vidd tovább az
értéket adj hozzá valami többletet ahhoz
ami most itt megjelent a világunkban és
nem úgy értettem ahogy a posztmodern kor
hozza közel hogy egy nyughatatlanság
satöbbi tehát valahogy úgy fogalmaznék
még kiegészítésként hogy annyira a gyors
információk korát éljük nincsenek
elidőzéseink pedig a csöndben csöndül
föl az elidőzés válasza az elidőzésben
adott válasz csönd nélkül nem tud menni
egy picit úgy is fogalmaznék hogy az
információs
időszak vagy ez a kor amit élünk tehát
gyors impulzusokat hoz de valahol pont
attól fosztd meg hogy a csendnek az
ereje és a nek a súlya vigyen bennünket
abba az irányba hogy méen gondolkodjak
el azon hogy mi az én irányom hol tartok
most hová szeretnék eljutni